cooking is about using heat to create
chemical reactions in the food cookus
food isn't just hot food it's
fundamentally different if you cook
something and you put it in the fridge
and make it cold it's still cooked it's
just cold now it doesn't go back to its
same state whereas if you take a piece
of metal make it hot cool it down it's
pretty much the same as it was before
there's a chemical and irreversible
chemical change now chemistry teaches us
that chemical changes usually require
both time and temperature and the rate
at which a chemical reaction will occur
is some function of time and temperature
broadly speaking there's a whole set of
foods for which the chemical reactions
we call cooking happen very fast so fast
that pretty much the instant you reach a
temperature it's done now if it's not at
that temperature may not be done yet but
doneness means bring to a temperature
and then you're done that's it there's
another set of foods where the chemical
reactions are fundamentally much more
slow and in those slow reactions we have
to Co hold the food at a particular
temperature for a period of time most
foods that are in the fast group would
include fruits vegetables eggs and fish
and tender meats if you are cooking a
filet mignon as soon as it reaches a
certain temperature it's done you know
for me I like rare about 120 degrees
Fahrenheit
I like medium-rare to be about 130
degrees Fahrenheit and so the minute the
second the actually tiny fraction of a
second that it reaches a hundred and
thirty it's done but tough meats are
fundamentally different tough meats that
would be cuts like brisket like short
ribs like skirt steak any of these tough
cuts of beef or of any other meat for
that matter even tough stewing chickens
or other the leg meat of ground dwelling
birds like ducks or pheasants
that tough meat is tough because it has
something called collagen in it now
collagen is a topic totally under itself
but for our purposes here the thing
that's different about cooking these
Tufts needs is that we have to cook them
long enough to soften that collagen in
traditional cooking that usually means
cooking a stew or a braise a typical
stewar braise you might cook for an hour
two hours three hours even overnight in
some cases and that's what traditional
cooking was about it was about saying
let's cook this stuff very slowly but at
moderately high temperature as a result
braised or stewed meat tends to be gray
it tends to be dry because via that high
temperature also because of collagen
winds up wringing the meat out from the
inside out with sous-vide cooking we can
cook at a precise temperature for as
long as we like and we can actually
cheat this collagen curve we can get a
rare or medium rare like meat that's
still nice and red it's still nice and
juicy but still degrade the college and
make that meat tender but to do that we
have to extend our cooking times very
long that's because most chemical
reactions follow what's called are
geniuses law or our hineses first law of
chemical reactions that they are
exponential in temperature so that means
that the more you increase the
temperature the faster they go at a
dramatic rate with most food chemical
reactions if you drop the temperature by
10 degrees
you increase the cooking time by a
factor of 10 to get the same results if
it's in this slow set of cooking around
collagen as a result we will do
sous-vide cooking for 24 48 72 or even
in one example of oxtail recipe we have
in Modernist Cuisine 100 hours now that
requires a little planning ahead you
don't come home from work and say hey
hon let's have a hundred our oxtail you
kind of have to plan that in advance
the interesting thing is by cooking that
oxtail for 100 hours or short rib for 72
hours or pork ribs for 48 hours you get
a texture that is totally unlike what
you would get from braising it's
delicious it's unexpected it's a way to
take a meat and reinvent it as something
entirely new and use something that's
both got a lot of flavor in it and it's
usually pretty cheap because we
generally price meats according to how
tender they are